I'm Sean Evans and you're watching hot
ones it's the show with hot questions
and even hotter wings it's a very
special episode for a number of reasons
first I'm joined by the icon Tony Hawk
oh let's hear it for Tony and then
number two we are live from complex con
so this is the first time we've ever
done it live anything could happen
we could lose an icon today for all I
know Tony give me you owe me hear it
John breaking my heart how are you with
hot food I like to think I'm pretty good
I tend to order on the spicier side and
I tend to gravitate towards spicier food
so I don't know I've seen your show and
I've seen how people think they can do
it so I'm not making any claims well are
you ready to test the women I'm ready
yes all right so this first one is
sriracha and you know about Sarat yes no
big deal okay
yep that's Rochon hidden
so recently you've made headlines for
your Halloween costume you get great
Larry David costume but those who pay
attention to tony hawk know that you
knock it out of the park every year so
what I've done is I've pulled your last
three Halloween costumes I want to know
what I do you choose wondering if like
who you are that year evarin forms how
you do the skate session oh that sounds
good yeah okay where does it that one
you hasn't ever informed the skate
session does it in no I just figure if
I'm gonna go all out and do a costume I
might as well get a skate shot in it
right to make it interesting and
obviously have a park in my backyard so
that makes it easy but um yeah I just
think it's funny like like this last one
I did Larry David I thought it'd be
hilarious just Larry David skating it
was hilarious to see Larry David skating
here is Larry David skating why Larry
David pratip pretty good why'd you pick
Larry Daymond um I love curb you
enthusiasm and I heard it was come back
for a night season and I just came to me
like that that's that's what I want to
do it and I got a couple of Hollywood
makeup artists help me and send a chair
about three hours I'm gonna head out
along the process about three hours they
wanted to do it well she wanted to do it
more like actual prosthetics on my face
and make it really real and I said it's
just my you know it's just our party
doesn't I'm not going on camera I like
not doing a TV show I'm not on Curb Your
Enthusiasm so we can do the three hour
session not the nine what about Peter
over here is this last year yeah that
was last year that came about because
because I love that that mockumentary
what we do in the shadows and my oldest
son Riley is in a isn't a band and they
named themselves Peter after him and
when he said that I was considering a
Halloween costume right then and I
thought that's what I want to do fate
yeah Kevin stop here as well Kevin's
been with my best friend's since I was
about 12 years old and Kevin has a very
iconic look so his was not hard to
duplicate all had to do was was a dye my
hair and get his girlfriend to steal all
of his clothes so that's literally I'm
wearing his clothes for body them all
yeah are you ready to move on sure so
this next one is Tapatio okay that's
pretty much what we we put up to you
almost everything in homes oh I hope I'm
ready you're ready
yes that's actually a little mellower
mm-hmm are you trying to trick me
backwards we're not going backwards they
all hit people differently we're just
going guys Koval skull bit arc like
remember this moment appreciate this
okay all right I got it from all
accounts are pretty adventurous eater
it's not just today so what I want to
know is first what's like the strangest
thing you've ever eaten in your life you
think tarantula a tarantula flash-fried
yeah how'd that taste it just tasted
like twigs didn't really I honestly just
like kind of a mouthful of dirt that's
crunchy well what you might not know is
that I've actually spoken to some of the
people that you hang out with every day
some behind-the-scenes people and they
gave me a list of things that you've
eaten that are all kind of crazy so I
want to just bounce them off of you and
you tell me what you remember about it
okay
whale blubber whale blubber um wait it's
not I'm not loud taco so like that are
we not is that a thing I don't know uh
that was actually served to me at that
famous restaurant that got shut down
yeah and I didn't know it was just that
they were it was omakase so they were
just serving what they had and I found
out later that's what it was whale
blubber out in taste I mean I'm not
gonna lie it was pretty good it was it
was like good sushi worms worms
mealworms they are just kind of squishy
and not a lot of flavor not very good
what about crickets crickets are
crickets just tastes like like crunchy
snacks pretty good don't ya not how
about scorpions um I I can't see I got a
really good taste of scorpions the
scorpions I had we're kind of on on
crust
you know something like a bruschetta of
scorpions and it's like pretty good
yeah well the bread was good so I was
kind of milk I don't think I think they
were trying to hide it you know trying
to hide it yeah all right well and now
we got a respect Tony Hawk just sitting
there chomping down video eggs just
snacking on them are you really - damn
here
only too deep you ready to go three deep
sure so this next one I'll Yucatec Oh
chili habanero I feel like I don't want
to know the names of the sauces we don't
you want to be blind to it that would be
and also I don't usually drink milk by
itself so bottles up
that was pretty good
you enjoy that one yeah alright so I
want to stick on the topic of food
because I know it's one of your passions
it's one of your obsessions and if you
look for me I have a Tony Hawk sort of
quickfire food round table you ready go
yes all right what's the spiciest thing
you've ever eaten wasabi oil how'd that
days where'd you have at some sushi
restaurant I can't remember and they it
was kind of like the secret you know the
show back room is what we have and I
actually dipped it into the dish and my
mouth stopped functioning when I put in
it well we'll see we'll probably
recreate that see how about the best
sushi ever um my I think the best sushi
is sushi though in LA this one in West
LA the one downtown the fish is
exceptional but they could be one piece
at a time and they relate they spruce it
up a little bit but they don't overdo it
with you know different flavors um I
mean the best fish fish was in uh was at
Tsukiji in Tokyo where they actually
bring the fish in like the that's the
freshest you can get it right that's
pretty much where the sushi bars here
are getting it from but you go there and
right to the source there's a couple of
sushi bars in that area they open at
5:00 a.m. and there's already a line out
there out the door so you got to get
there like 4:30 a.m. to get in and then
you go sit down and they just serve you
the freshest fish that just came off the
boat
sushi heipiess and pretty much kick you
out right afterwards yeah all right
laughs but most importantly what is your
deal with creme brulee what do you have
against creme brulee
we've been talking to uh I had it once
at this Italian place and got super sick
afterwards and you know when you just
associated a sickness or something you
ate mm-hmm that was it
Pavlov's dog you can't read you can't
hit it again yeah and so every time I
see someone like break through the crust
of creme brulee I get that feeling like
oh the blood rushes out of your head you
get sick tears I just I just feel like I
don't I don't want to go there
how you doing so far pretty good we 3d
that this one's pretty hot knocking a
lot the next one's a little bit hotter
you ready to move on okay so this next
one is pain is good louisiana-style
pain is good pain is good
louisiana-style
it sounds like some bad boy club shirt
logo
what makes out louisiana-style
that one's got flavor you like it yeah
this is the one pain is good as a great
hot sauce the next three I love so but
this one really like it's not just hot
it actually has some flavor it's kind of
yeah it's profound it's profound it's my
bus
I want to talk about the show Tony
strange light that you did for the ride
channel because I always find it
fascinating when someone who's been
interviewed a million times decides to
get onto the other side of the table be
interviewed a million times how did that
affect how you prepared for those sorts
of interviews um well I found that just
having more fluent conversation was
better than having a bunch of prepared
questions I mean definitely I want to be
well researched and who I was talking to
but sometimes I did that show just on
the fly I was like I found myself next
to some you know someone interesting and
it's like let's just shoot it interview
real quick but I've been doing radio
show over 10 years now and I've learned
you know what works and what doesn't and
how to keep the conversation going so I
felt like I was prepared but but
sometimes it's just off the cuff why did
you want to do it just because I found
myself in these crazy situations where
and having access to people that I find
really interesting and having questions
on my own so I just started kind of
doing it on the fly I mean it wasn't
like I wasn't like I was setting out to
have some career as an interviewer was
just more look at these crazy situations
what are you interested in coz like for
me I'm always interested in how these
people tick like what makes them tick
what sorts of things were you interested
in when you're gonna sit down with
someone um I'm interested in the process
for sure and I'm in the background a bit
but all that stuff seems you've been
told by them already right so many times
that it sounds for herse when they say
it and you as someone who's been
interviewed a gazillion times probably
recognized that way on anyone because
you get sick of answering the same
questions so it's more like like I got
to talk to Louie CK about internet
haters and being on the other side of
that and how you deal with that and what
and how and how sometimes you can call
them out and then they're you know they
back off and exactly that's an
interesting subject to me and that's not
like coming from the perspective of
someone that is just watching it from
afar it's someone who experiences out on
the daily right you know and and so I
think that's an interesting perspective
to have for someone who's watching it
because you face those challenges just
like they face those channels and
they're probably more comfortable
sharing those shared experiences yeah
you know it's pretty hot this one's what
you learn about yourself because
sometimes you can learn a lot about
yourself by asking people questions um
that I'm not Howard Stern and I really
want to be brothers of how I talk to
people
whoa what are you are you having trouble
so am i winning right now it's early
it's really it's early sometimes it
grows it I'm factually had done the
wrong L addressed don't get cocky so
sorry I play Oregon Jay told you don't
get cocky yeah all right so this next
one is the hot ones hot sauce you're on
the hot one show so you know how that
goes wait he's actually licensed this
has my name on the bottle look at this
whoa boom how about that you're
impressed
yeah and it's very it's rather
intimidating that's small right it's
like kind of like a flower yeah yeah but
I'll think you'll find that it's
actually more of like a pleasant sauce
you'll find I'm not trying to influence
your
then that's exactly middle to run mm-hmm
but that is that is a pleasant sauce you
like it Tony yes is thank you Tony
good job how do you come up with
oh wait super minor well it's not like
well no how do you come up with a unique
stas out of all these so what happened
was a homeboys hot sauce which is this
he's a hot sauce maker in Phoenix and
he's a great hot sauce maker and we
partnered with him so he made it it
wasn't like me and Chris are like you
know we have a bathtub and we're making
the stuff ourselves on this always apart
I think that's when I pictured but it
was very like we were trying like we
tried to miso-based we try to habanero
base you try a chipotle base like we
were very much like with the lab coats
on like China and we and we talked it
through we're like we make the world's
hottest sauce do we make like it and
that's what we settled on that's the
product so I enjoy it's yes thumbs up
that's not just because I'm on the show
I'm not getting paid or anything
Wow it's good so I want to talk about
skate locations because you've skated at
some amazing places you've skated the
New York Stock Exchange you've skated
the White House but I have to think that
there's some sort of Moby Dick out there
I have to think that there's a place
that you've been told it's impossible
you can't get you can't do it is there
some spot that's like on your bucket
list it's the targets a number-one thing
um no I've never I didn't really have a
bucket list like is more than I found
myself in those places and I had you
know somewhat approval to do that so it
was just like oh I'm gonna do that I
wasn't like I set out I honestly went to
the White House because I was invited
there for a Father's Day event and
brought my skateboard only because when
I go to something like that and I don't
have my skateboard that's the first
question where's your skater seaboard I
was like all right I'm not gonna get
caught like that the White House right
and then found myself walking down the
hall and it was like hey if I you know
if I might be the first you shoot a
photo and the guys my tour guide mascot
was like if you say you know as long as
you don't say I shot it but obviously
there's gotta be cameras everywhere they
missed him you know I mean they must
have known that we were
what did you make of the reaction
because there are some uptight pundits
who like really went after them yeah for
that can I say I was I was invited there
because I was a skateboarder I was
celebrating what got me there I was
right hurting anything I wasn't wasn't
grinding any statue anyone while riding
grinded be a oval office or anything
I wish all right you ready to move on
yeah
yes I think so
this one are going to do that I see when
you do that when I do as always you're
like it's a it's a we doing next level
it's weird I used to do it like when I
played sports in high school like
sometimes I would do it and I hadn't
done it and like what ever since like
2005 and then through this show it's
like a really it's like come out of the
ashes it's weird I wish I didn't it's
just a weird thing yeah but my frame
reference is like that means we're going
that that's that's true that is what it
means
so this one is High River rogue number
six we're now in the back nine Tony and
you're doing pretty good
okay how are you feeling pretty good I
think
[Music]
that was good that was not as flavorful
as yours Tony I'm gonna market a
thousand thank yous a thousand thank you
smoking if you if you could that'd be
awesome we'd appreciate that so this
one's hot it is a little hot and that
segues rather poetically into this
because by virtue of doing this stupid
show I've eaten the hottest peppers in
the world I've eaten some of the hottest
hot sauces in the world but it's never
enough for anyone it's always like you
don't try this you got to try this this
is 6 billion Scoville Sean you'll die
and I'm always like well I'm good on
that I'm good on that I don't need to do
it but I imagine it's probably pretty
similar to you like you land in 900 and
people are like well what's next you do
the horizontal loop and people are like
what's next is there ever been a time
where a brand or a skater somebody has
brought a challenge to you and you're
like no no no no I can't do that well
not really because all the challenges
I've created myself so it was more like
for me it was what's next so you know
for instance 900 like I learned 720 as
when in 1985 in Sweden at the summer
camp and it's like what's the next stage
of spinning 900 so I you know tried
those throughout the years and so it was
more like what is next what's
progression and then I did the loop and
we built a loop for our boom of Hakeem
tour and I always thought like what if
you turn that thing sideways and it's
weird because that would seem easier
than going all the website down but
really sticking to a wall a 90-degree
wall the physics of the whole 360 um it
was painful it was way hard I thought it
would be what's your mindset like when
you try something like that for the
first time uh my mind set on that and
that particular one was to approach it
like a loop approach it like it's one
long car
and I was making the same mistakes that
I made the first time trying to loop
like I could not get my mind and my body
to co-op to coordinate that I mean it
took a while I was it was like like I
said it's harder than I thought and when
I finally did it it was like I never
ever want to do that again and I know I
could design it better and maybe make it
not easier but maybe a little easier
yeah do you get kind of obsessed with
those things like what you can change
right it has to right yeah yeah I mean
I'm new I know exactly how to build that
thing properly so it worked for someone
else now what I built
I actually molded it into my vert ramp
which made the transition get tighter as
you went so the more torque you have the
tide of the transition got which was the
worst possible scenario really it seems
like that would be like create more for
us to go through her now because as you
coming around you want that open the
transition to open up and so I would
make it actually just a ribbon and not
make it mold into a vert room even
though that you know the risk of that is
that you just fall from the sky I don't
know what can I say well someone has you
right you had to I had to it in the
world's better for it are you ready to
move on yeah but your body motions are
freaking me out
it's all freaking me out this all tangs
freaky there was this now it's like this
so this next one is pain 100% a
particularly good tasting hot sauce in
my opinion but it hits you but it hits
you how you feeling
I feel okay good right yeah I'm sweating
good good as a relative term this one
worries me because the color of this
wing is much redder than the other ones
that's the thing some of these look
radioactive I kind of want to ask you
what what are the worst-case scenarios
but I don't really want to know the
worst-case scenarios on this no I need
for your show like what like where could
it go I don't know oh no I don't know we
don't know the limits that's what
probably will take it down
I think it is your job
oh damn that one's hot that's that's the
point that's the point that was my job
it is my job this is no hobby for me I'm
gonna toss that skin right there oh wow
now I get it right not yeah I got it
this is where the game changes for sure
so you have the first overall pick in a
celebrity skate Draft
Lil Wayne Justin Bieber Tyler the
Creator who are you picking and why um
Wow well Tyler Tyler isn't he's the best
one out of those yeah what do you see
when you walk ups and Hopson ribs absent
is he like the best yeah Radley he does
he does triple kick flips that dudes
legit really yeah you're impressed by
him yeah yeah and you're impressed by
Tyler mm-hmm are there any other famous
people who you're like well they're
actually legitimately good skateboarders
so I mean like this generation grew up
skating so I can't the you know the
field is huge now for who can skate and
who who's legit who ribs so shout out to
Hopson shout out to Tyler the Creator
yes sir low jazzy good I shouted them
out we have shouted them out no Hopson
came to my office and and did my radio
show and then we did a Facebook live
thing and he was taking requests for
tricks and really damn no it's hot for
real yep
Wow that's the thing about the show
that's like our point yeah got it all
right so this next one is de bomb beyond
in San move the next one or if you're
ready are you ready Tony we're working
our way through you're doing really well
I'll tell you that one hit me hard just
know he'll hit yeah it'll hit you yeah
look he's I really help what is it milk
really hope I find that nothing really
helps all that much when you really
break it down alright so this one the
bomb beyond insanity whoo
so it's impossible to interview Tony
Hawk at complex con and not bring up
Pharrell I know that you guys are kind
of kindred spirits in a way I know that
you guys see a lot of similarities and
what I want to do because that guy is
always going big and so I have three
things that he's doing this weekend but
one of them is a lie okay one of them is
a lie and you have to tell me which is
the lie so two of these are true one of
them is a lie for Retel at complex con
right I'll give you the three things you
decided with what's the lie
pop-up tribal dance moments to protest
the Dakota access pipeline unveiling a
fashion collaboration in a garden full
of denim jeans curating an art
installation based on the deleted tweets
of celebrities a third one is to meta
let's do meta and you nailed it that's
the lie all right you aren't curious
that's that's my next creative project
okay when hot ones we drive this into
the ground that's my next creative
project no mana aria we're good I just
yeah thank you
I used to meet you drinking the angel
crashing you want just ha what happened
ah here you go you wanna imagine what is
that was the hot what's the hottest one
we're almost to the end eros the end so
yeah don't touch hi Augie Angela bump a
chair
don't do hi-oh do hi-c take a bite
goodbye kisses oh that's not as one is
it do it oh damn dude Lord forgive me
for my language
it's alright cut him hot wouldn't water
you just did hot you see that right go
you just did the hottest just shut us
down be some meal appreciate oh yeah
yeah yeah thank you
you don't have a game or anything
therefore the interest open it that's
the hot ones live difference Wow
I had a show he just he just Holly it oh
yeah I'll dab this other side alright so
no more to go
that was impressive alright I'll take
some more milk whoo
I never thought I'd say this but I'll
take another basketball oh yeah we need
more milk
where's Dominique with the milk I get a
topper - he's sweating Thank You Dom
this when you can't see the aftermath
Angela it's pretty good over here
he just got a milk to go
now I see the benefits of doing it live
at complex huh yeah D'Angelo Russell
just my passion so this next one is Mad
Dog 357 is our second hottest hot sauce
Merle there Tony we're almost there
all right not a fun one boom
just on you this one comes in like it's
gonna taste good right
but then when it hits oh well yeah I
Tony yep so you reach I was like like
when you do your first shot of whiskey
or something like oh that was pretty
good more than you do the cringe face
yeah start chewing gum so I'm biting on
your sweatshirt so using all warm all of
a sudden you recently posted a picture
on Instagram with Tom Green and Johnny
Knoxville and for better or worse a lot
of us nineties kids we were raised by
you 3 icon idea
and at that height when you're hanging
out on the jackass set or you're goofing
off with Tom Green on a red carpet and
your experience what's the most severe
way they've ever violated you hang out
with those guys uh well it wasn't by
their own doing but when I did wild boys
we did a thing with this chimp and
skated and then we were all dressed like
chimps and then we're a Bob Burnquist
house and we're trying to get some skate
footage in the chimp costumes and then
uh we try to do his loop and his loop
was weathered and slow and I paid the
price getting cocky and and I broke my
pelvis
oh no but I don't blame them but it was
you know it was in the context of doing
their show but it's all on me hanging
around those jackass guys they always
talk about it themselves like if you if
you tit if you put your guard down you
have to watch out you keep you have to
keep your head on a swivel because
someone's coming in with a crazy print
when you're on talent set especially
jackass yeah on set you see everyone
standing around like this for real like
when they're covering their crotches yep
or if you have a drink you just deal
like this because they've all been there
because someone's gonna pour some in it
or pee in it or whatever or someone if
you're like this they're gonna hit you
in the crotch so it's like a catch-22
know that you're going to get yeah
either a shot to the nuts or embarrassed
with something in your glass yeah you're
ready to move on to the hottest blair's
make a death sauce with liquid rage all
right
one more buy this one same with than I
will - you know what because that's the
kind of host I am Oh
as you know it is tradition around here
to dab the last wing Tony you don't have
to if you don't want to it's ok you
don't have to if you don't want to I
just do a little little dab for the
people this is gonna clump bad I can
already tell oh you don't do that don't
do that Wow
now you just try to make up for add
Angelo coming in and I don't want to
leave anything to chance I don't want
people saying Oh DeAngelo you'd have to
wing Shan like whatever big glob big
glob making up for it how's that that's
perfect that's perfect for the people or
Oh more what oh great thank you yeah
live audience alright more I'm just
giving the people what they want
are your people right there mad people
there are people ok here we go all right
Oh God of all the bones that you've
broken over the course of your career
which was the most painful and how does
it compare to Blair's Megadeth sauce
with liquid Rach
well the most painful I hate to go back
to that injury but was breaking my
pelvis how does that feel it feels way
worse than this okay that's good when
you break your pelvis you can't do
anything you can't they don't really I
mean I didn't how I couldn't get it put
back together so you have to just sit
and you can't make any sudden movements
you can't coffee can't sneeze going to
the bathroom is like insane task um it
was it was the worst yeah it was it was
the the time I got really really good at
other video games other than my own
that's cuz ya'll you're doing stuff up
the gamer chain yeah Tony Hawk you made
it through let's all hear
and you gave it all to us you gave it
all to us but we give it back 30 second
blog we really roll out the red carpet
this camera that camera that camera let
the people know what you have going on a
gift huh oh we got red channel
that's uh that's our escape that's her
skate site YouTube channel and I'm
working on the next birdhouse video we
have done a video in almost 10 years and
the other guys literally in Oklahoma
right now shooting Shaw's band Clint
David Loy Sean Hale Lizzie Armand toe
and I'm super excited that's coming out
next year and uh thanks for having me
hey let's do it again Victoria that's
right
Alaska looking back yeah I think like do
it like this one is actually probably
like the worst morning yeah the one
before that was worse yeah well